all right so let's move off the
political angle on Syria for a minute
let's actually talk about Syria and
what's happening there because I think
that's the part that's getting lost in
this so over a hundred thousand people
have died in two years that's more
people that have been killed in the
entire arab-israeli conflict since 1948
I mean it's absolutely horrific over a
thousand people died obviously in that
chemical attack John Kerry last week was
calling Assad Hitler and now we've
agreed somehow that we're gonna let
Hitler stay we're just gonna take away
certain his special weapons and again I
was against this altogether but is is
this did our own rhetoric now get us
crazed because now we're just gonna even
if we take the chemical weapons away
Assad can go back to killing yesterday
he started using more planes to kill
again for the first time in weeks
because he know he knows he has passed
but this is where I think this
administration can push it not push it
away from themselves but at least later
say this something else happens again or
even if I saw on a much smaller scale
like well we kick this to the UN well we
went through Congress we did everything
that you guys said that you that you
would like for us to do to do it in a
diplomatic and democratic way we did
this way and now can any blame come back
on us of course a certain percentage can
because of you know the the way that we
built it up yeah it was such a big deal
but when quote Hitler gets back to doing
the things he was doing as we described
him it's kind of hard to say that why
didn't we take him up and this is one of
the lines actually that Obama mentioned
that I thought was pretty good he
mentioned that we every time there's
something wrong somewhere else in the
world they said well where's America to
clean this up whereas America to stop
this this dictator and then he said so
then when I say let's go and do
something about this dictator you go
whoa what are you trying to do take over
the world for it goes which way do you
want me to go here and is that why we
get caught by our own rhetoric because
obviously they were trying to push us to
war and that's why Kerry said Hitler
because everybody hates Hitler yeah but
now - if you really want get the green
light but now it's like well we're
letting Hitler stay if we're going with
the Hitler analogous so much I mean it
is it's it really has not it wasn't the
smoothest plan I mean the thing is it's
like oh god here here comes the chemical
weapons and then Obama's like I got to
be the strong dude because
everyone feels like he gets walked all
over he's like that's my that's my line
I'm not gonna you know we can't cross it
and then it's like well no no nobody
wants it okay okay plan to what else
what else we got and then it's like if
we're literally it must be so bad if
we're like Putin's got a really good
idea we're gonna get behind Russia which
was I mean that on carry mistake just
talk about the humanitarian part of this
obviously the hundred thousand is awful
yeah do we know I mean what if another
hundred thousand people die like is
there a magic number if the UN is just
incapable of doing anything because of
China and Russia veto is there a number
that as humans as Americans do we have
any place in the world to try to save
people that are being slaughtered or is
that is that God is that out of the
American ethos at this point maybe is
because of what we've done yeah again no
one trusts us anymore
I mean if we weren't involved in these
wars that had nothing to do with us say
we weren't and then we never went into
Iraq we haven't been threatening Iran
for the past eight years about what's
going on with the nuclear facilities you
know about do something about that now
there's factions of Americans are doing
I'm not saying that's been our policy
but there's factions that have been
calling for it forcing us to think about
it so because of the aggressive nature
that we've been coming at people it's
hard for us to have any kind of
credibility to say when humanitarian
issues happen and we want to clean up
there's always suspicion and it's how do
we fix that that's the only question I
have any other answer how do we fix what
our past is our past say 12 15 years has
set up for people to not trust us to do
anymore even American people we're
thinking you're making up stuff to go
into war and why do we believe that
because we made up stuff to go into war
that I do think there's the only part of
me that would have been okay with this
at any level would have been the
humanitarian part to stop people from
getting killed I don't care if people
are getting killed by gas or by regular
weapons as usually dead people don't
care either which way they went
but it does strike me I agree with you
that we're sort of in a no-win situation
the world won't do anything when there
is when there's evil and if we don't do
anything then do we just that strikes me
as like well then everyone
just out world everyone's out for
themselves but maybe that's by others
there's the fallout of all these
countries of Egypt of Libya of Iraq of
Afghanistan where we have gone in we've
gone in we've changed the landscape of
the country we've pulled so you know
so-called the bad guys out and it is
been chaos absolute chaos and when
you're dealing with a country what
whatever country that is you know in the
Middle East or wherever where you've got
so many religious factions and you pull
out like sort of the central authority
which I'm not saying is like a good
thing or a bad thing whatever this
evildoer yeah
then you've just you know we just try to
insert democracy in all these countries
that were democracy in fact maybe
doesn't work they were run by a dictator
for 30 years that we backed then they
had a revolution against the dictator
they they decide to vote for the first
time they vote for the Muslim
Brotherhood who's more extreme than the
dictator and then they have a coup
although we don't call it a coup to then
take out the democratically elected guy
by the way we don't hear about Egypt
anymore so I guess that whole thing
worked out right so it's all right so
then what happened so we go in on
humanitarian level take him out get
these weapons out where you are where
you put the weapons I guess you put them
in what Siberia and and then and then
what happens then what happens you know
like it's just it's absolute chaos that
the rest of the world can be perfect
when first off our country isn't but we
preached it they can be just as perfect
as America and then as soon as we preach
it we have to kind of back the least
negative leader yeah and then we go okay
we're back in someone and nothing
Horrible's happened just bad things yeah
let's kind of back up and be quiet
maybe that's the last for 10 years yeah
well in America's defense we usually
vote for the least evil leader too so
very good